did you pick up a Nintendo switch over
the weekend well you're definitely not
alone I'm Tony this is a GameSpot news
update and for all the most important
video game sales figures be sure to
subscribe the switch is Nintendo's
fastest selling console ever Nintendo of
America president Reggie fils-aime sold
more in its first week than any other
system in the company's history that
includes the Nintendo 64 3ds and even
the Wii which is now the second fastest
seller on top of that Zelda breadth of
the wild is the best-selling standalone
launch game in Nintendo history although
it's definitely not expected to top Wii
Sports and overall sales but that's
because that game was bundled with the
Wii
still Bravo Nintendo the switch
certainly had a giant marketing push
from a Superbowl commercial to a
partnership with WWE legend John Cena
and we've got reviews for all of its
hottest games so head over to GameSpot
for our thoughts on Zelda 1 to switch
and super Bomberman R and for all the
biggest Nintendo news you're already in
the right place
[Music]